what was the story where I've been
Harvey want to meet you back yes
somewhere I was at the Comedy Store in
LA and I had just gotten off in the main
room and the manager at the time came uh
came out and was like I need to talk to
you now I'm running to another set I
can't he called me he was at Harvey
Weinstein's here you got to get back
here right now he wants you back here
and I was like uh I'm going to another
set and I literally didn't go back so I
was like how the lighting in the Comedy
Store is really bad
oh he thinking like if he's thinking of
you for a project was like like my
vanity probably view protected me from
whatever nightmare that was gonna be I
was like no he saw me in a good
spotlight like I should just stop while
I'm ahead and wonder what he wanted you
for I don't know well vanity saved you
you did it really did know how hungry
you were in show business I'm surprised
you just didn't go immediately because
when he didn't when he calls you run I
am i I woulda I'm so you know me I'm so
awkward and weird I would have ruined it
my personality would have roan